I want the girl to be adequately into it
yes I want her to be so if she has to be
persuaded to do it by the time at least
she's put up a no and she wasn't into it
so I trust her judgment yeah and then
when she is into it I'm like oh she's
real Horne doctor wants it so I trust
that she's now turned on during it as
opposed to just going through the
motions yes or like I hate it when like
if anybody looks very uncomfortable with
it I hate that it's just like if
somebody's gagging or whatever like
somebody's like forcing angle or
something I hate that yeah you mean
Tuesday's that's married
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's you up with Nikki Glaser we're back
Tom Dakar is here
Bonnie McFarlane is here and now des
Bishop comedian des Bishop is back with
us comedian to make sure that's clear
comedian s Bishop well what it was
comedian is fine yes but recently I did
a show in West Hampton over the summer
and I always spend my summers there so I
was very excited to get my name up on
the marquee yeah and finally the day
before the show they put up Dez Bishop
tomorrow night and then the next day
when I went there they had changed it to
comedian Dez Bishop helped stop
apartheid no it's it probably was to
sell people love comedians they and yeah
it's absolutely fine I saw I could say I
had no I had a lot of personal like like
hand to hand tickets house because I
know so many people out there those last
few tickets they felt that was Williams
was on the night before and she ate it
and I actually pretty much sold it out
so they were like we lost our shirt on
Vanessa Williams you saved that's nice
it was a hometown show like a lot of
people from high school juice from my
Golf Club and a lot of people from the
beach okay do you get how do you feel
about performing for people you know do
you love it
well I don't love it that one was a
little Oh tea tea
I'd say 35 percent of the audience were
people that I directly who titi a very
common expression in our I've been in
Cabin Ireland I've been encountering
these more and more where I say things
thinking that totally no more than
Americans are like what yeah yeah JC is
one of those amazing over-the-top I
don't know them I'm right it's only when
people react to what I say love acronyms
that's an acronym right yeah there's the
acronym the winner
without something yeah I think it's I
think we're TT would be but yeah but
there's one that if it spells some right
like if it's spelt if we called it scuba
scuba that's different than that one's
an acronym and ones like initialism
initial so acronym is an abbreviation
form from the initial letters of the
other words and pronounced as a word I
always do when I go wow I always do like
charity shows when I go back home so
that if I if it stink I don't feel bad
making my friends and family pay because
it's going to a good cause and if I
stink it's like it's for the dogs yeah
the charity is the Nikki Glaser
foundation but also you have these weird
moments where like somebody you know
heckles you so you're sort of you rip on
them and 30% of the audience think it's
the funniest thing ever and everybody
else is like what that was Bob when I
was in Edmonton this woman was like I
started talking to her she kept her
table kept talking kept shouting you
know whatever not really heckling but
you know and they like add something
sure yeah and then I started talking to
him and she goes I know you I know you
from childhood and I was like you know
it's hard to see when you're on stage
she said her name I didn't recognize it
you're not memorable and it was like you
know plus you're trying to keep things
lively for the audience you want to get
deep into real and then so then I you
know sort of started making fun of her
but she was offended but she she came up
to me after the show and she was like
she was like I guess you don't remember
me that's the right time to really like
she sent a picture of her and I to the
club when we were like you know six and
seven years old for some kind of like
VIP trip I don't know like to prove
could you let Bonnie see this you said
you'd recognize me forever one of those
governor's clubs yeah and a bunch of
girls that I was in primaries grammar
school with one of them held up a
picture of me from second grade on a
stick that's so I was kind of fun was
right at the beginning then they pipe
down okay that's good if they it was
kind of funny like I don't know I I
would I think I'd mention this last week
even but I was heckled recently by a guy
who like had a funny heckle and I was
like attracted confident I was just like
who the do you think you are go K
like yes to somebody's got a big car I
wonder you exactly I'm like I wanna be
like disrespect it's a little
disrespectful you should make that porn
you know what it was funny he what he'd
I think um I think I think I was talking
about this I'm doing this new bed about
like don't let guys come unless they
like doesn't really earn it and and then
he just goes Oh God come on cut like he
was doing he was on a date and he was
like this is a date I'm not like yeah
playing a character it was a funny over
the top like response to it and then I
kind of talked to him and he had some
good lines that I was like can I use
that like it was good impressed you guys
work shopped a bit live on stage yeah
I've got I've taken a couple my closing
joke is something that a dude in the
front row gave me during the show
chlamydia he just like under his breath
like the whole show he was quiet and
then I did this joke about getting
fingered in an uber and I call it uber
finger
and the joke itself was already worked
out it had a good closing line and then
he just goes Ober eats and I was like
there's something there and I was like
can I have that and he goes weird taking
that line so I just reached in my pocket
and whatever I had in there I gave him
$3 yeah I was like I just bought that
joke from you so you can I think in that
scenario hand job would have been a more
- payment god no thank you no thank you
I don't hand it out like a jobs I mean
I'm sure it's much more about the
getting okay they get you out of a lot
of jams when you like 17 18 years old
I'm sure but as a woman giving them like
unless you think you're good at them
which is my whole thing like women only
like to do things they think they're
good at I don't I definitely know I'm
not good at hand jobs but also I'm let's
say I have the same skills skill set
level like I'm equally good at blow jobs
as hand jobs right and I only wanted to
do something I'm kind of good at I would
rather give a blowjob because I don't
have to like look at you while I'm doing
this thing that I'm not that it's my own
project as opposed to like a group
project where I'm not that confident do
you know what I mean yeah like a handjob
sort of feels like you're next if you're
like I know it's also like your data
compression in the context in a movie
theater you're gonna make out you gotta
focus on the popcorn thing
I mean you don't really need to give a
handjob after you're 20 years old but in
the context of paying a stranger for a
job let me give you a scenario and you
tell me what options I have as a woman
okay okay so hooking up I don't want to
have sex yet because that's it's sex
right that's like there's a lot at play
there that makes sense I'm not ready to
have sex and I don't want to blow you
because that's a your penis in my mouth
that is like a very intimate thing so
for for just that to be the go-to thing
yeah what's the scenario already started
answering the question okay so first
time hook up first time hook up with the
guy where you're like we're gonna get
into this clothes are coming off you
don't want to have sex with them but
you're not sure that you're ready to
suck his penis because like jerk him off
the assumption that you are you are you
concerned that you believe in the guy
hanging if you don't do something is
that your concern
but you weren't able to do something to
you though yeah but but also sometimes
the guy goes down I'm like no I don't
know that I want to yeah should a woman
feel obligated that's that's my that's
my question is that there is a sense of
obligation like what including myself
have gotten guys off when you didn't
really want to your heart wasn't in it
and in fact men can have sex with us
when we don't really even want it
because not like non-condensing but what
are our bodies what if we're not wet you
can just spit on us and make us wet
right and then you're having sex and
your body isn't ready for like it
doesn't really want it but it's like you
know you're hooking up with a guy and he
sits in his hand makes you wet then
you're wet it's like actually I'm not oh
it's wet no I guess it has to be filled
no but like you know do you know what
I'm talking about when a situation is
amping up and the guy thinks the girls
turned on enough and then she's not but
she's kind of asking for it but not like
and then you can just make yourself wet
by someone else's saliva which you can't
you can't make a guy hard by just doing
like spitting on well depends on the guy
I've never been able to stop making out
like once I've started making out with
someone I'm probably I like saying no a
hundred times and then having sex no I
mean these are all really interesting
conversations no means no Bonnie you
think let me just say I
I can always be convinced like if if I'm
making out with a guy I like you enough
that I could probably be convinced to
yes yeah but that's the problem is
like you want to be convinced but that's
where the confusion happens because then
sometimes you get in a situation like a
fellow comedian of ours he has quote
unquote read that situation correctly
then yeah that's right nowadays I don't
think it's you can't you have to be very
clear nowadays do you want it or do not
want it or if you're saying no right now
you're saying right now I'm not sure but
let's revisit this 15 minutes sometimes
I I just don't want to have an intimate
moment with someone if I think they're
going to disrespect me after it and
sometimes I'm not sure if that's gonna
happen or not
and I would hate I don't want to be
dealing with a guy not calling me who
I've given a blowjob to and I'm like how
dare I
it just feels to blow someone than
have them blow you off like it itches
well I shouldn't have done that
I shouldn't have done that yeah and
that's always by kind of initial anxiety
about blowing someone it's like this
could go what do you feel like that if
they went down on you first then I would
still feel rejected
that's the problem if like if you hook
up with a guy and he doesn't want to
continue hooking up with you even if you
don't want to continue hooking up with
him sure let's say you don't want to but
then he doesn't either
you feel rejected and you go oh I want
to now because he's rejecting me yeah
that's that's a deeper issue you know
yes yes it's I mean it and but don't
don't we all suffer that I mean I I'm
totally kidding I mean I I think I I
think the more important thing is that a
lot of men think that like it has to
happen for them and a lot of women think
they have to make it happen sure
otherwise he's gonna go crazy which I
can understand cuz physically you
literally want to go crazy if you think
it's gonna happen and it doesn't yes but
I do think the
conversation needs to be what does a guy
do in a situation where she doesn't want
to
and he thinks she's pushed him too far I
think the guy has to excuse himself in
Jericho personally that's why I said
this whole Lois thing was a bummer to me
because I used to like like when guys
would just jerk off because sometimes I
want you to come but I don't want to
touch you and I'm not ready to like
facilitate it but like I don't want you
to be weird in the present I want to
keep hanging out with the differences in
after you guys have been making out I'm
sorry let me um say that I meant by the
Loess thing it's like guys are now like
oh if I took off in front of a girl it's
a weird sex Louis thing and it's like no
it's like sometimes we like that yeah
right but I think also it's good to
acknowledge that physically it's a
little bit different for a guy than a
woman I'm assuming in that there is a
certain energy that can be hard to shut
off for a guy oh no it's Sonny who says
no no no she how you teach people
honestly if I was in a situation where I
was saying no for real I would hope the
person would know that but I'm in
situations where that's the dance you
know I believe in the dancers sure
that's me that's my thing
yeah I the lack of clarity is a problem
in our current discourse sure it's
amazing to me that more men I think that
I've started seeing like where more men
are that confused about it yeah I mean
and maybe I don't know maybe it's like
why would you be confused like I mean
like it's really kinda shy yeah it's
totally confused no I agree I think but
it's like I don't know it when you're in
that moment like I probably wouldn't
really
start heavily making out with someone
unless I already knew I was gonna have
sex with them so when you go I'm not
sleeping with you and you before you go
to their apartment that's all the dance
like some people will make out with
people that they don't want really not
gonna you when I say that but then
when we go up to your eye I want to give
guys hope and saying that if a girl is
making out with you and like has had sex
before and is free with her but she
could always be convinced if you show
her a good time like yeah just say not
always but like you can be convinced
when I've thought no like I'm not going
to if I will get to a point where I will
consent to it and be like oh I didn't
see this coming but now I have another
thing where I'm like I would feel a
little weird like maybe did I like in
retrospect after I'd be like did I like
make that like yeah that's why now I
have a form I have everybody sign and
that's what I signed when you came in
yeah it's it's complicated it's very
complicated
it's but I got some sex the other day I
talked about it on the radio and thirst
did I talk about it on Thursday that I
got sex on the way here on air or just
off air remember sexed I got on the way
to work
it was awesome I was I was having like a
bad like feeling like day where you're
just like I don't feel great about
myself uh-huh and then someone from my
past watch me I'm bumping mics and was
like you're so hot on this thing
I'm jerking off and I was just like wow
I was the one train just like what is
happening and it was awesome
and I just wanted to like give a shout
out to that guy for like making my
self-esteem boost like so much in a
moment when I need I literally wrote to
him I need at this thank you and he's
like good it's true
[Laughter]
it was great so I thank you for that
check out bumpy mics and jerk oh god I
don't even know if I want to say this
got a dick pic later one of my first
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've gotten one
before but it wasn't full like like I
liked it because it's just like oh my
god like I wasn't like yeah but it's a
dick you'd already seen some people ask
for them but I'm not into them yeah I
like them I like them I mean I they're
fun you're just like oh my god you're
one of two people who have ever heard
say they like them yeah ever you know
they just proposed a bill for making it
illegal illegal to send unsolicited dick
pics the problem the problem has been
that people have been air-dropping dick
pics to people in their proximity
Donovan Richards the politician who
proposed the bill from the anecdotes
that were in the article most times you
look up you can't tell who right right
yeah unless it's like the only black guy
she was like what would you what would
be funny to send back and I was like you
should have like a like a like a pic of
a dick ready and then say oh god that's
so gross have you ever seen dick on a
dick on the train no no I've like in the
wild white smoke I was masturbating
outside my roommates window that was
like that's gross
come on my window
come inside I'm gonna open it
[Music]
you